but anyways
um
yeah that's my confession
yeah that's a heavy one though that's
right you know what and we'll be right
back
you know the mickey mouse you know the
mickey mouse
watch we make a t-shirt with steve's
face that's that on a watch and steve's
going like this
you know what i just listened to well
you do his face on me yes and it's like
time stamp you know what i mean that
would be a great shoe
that's a good idea
that's actually a good idea
i usually don't i usually don't listen
to you yeah i know
and i know it drives you crazy it drives
me [ __ ] i just i was just listening
to and that's a fantastic idea stevie
did four sets with me oh you how did it
go you
thank you brandon i was so nervous that
last show can i just say something
because that room was friday night yeah
that was packed yeah and um
when uh when uh was his name justin the
mc yeah when he was doing his thing and
chris because christian and i were
standing near the back do you remember
that christian yeah and then i just
remember because i was sitting down and
you go are you ready but my mind was
whirling swirling because i'm like dude
this because this crowd has something
the show's packed these shows packed
because you know i knew it was pack
because you had to walk through the
crowd yeah i'm like dude this is packed
yeah but it's also supportive people
dude like that yeah like yeah it's like
that's the thing about any show that
like a person's doing like on the road
or anything like that where it's like a
specific person and the fans come out
it's always going to be a super
supportive environment and they're
familiar with you like they know you
they're just like it's dude
like we didn't announce anything so he
was just popping up so the audience
didn't know
and just like you know from king in this
thing it's stupid
yeah
you crushed that room oh thanks dude
yeah you crush it
water comedians why do you guys go
like what does that mean because you're
killing me like killing it you did you
did a gun because it was my last show
before i shot my special
i mean david david always goes how did
that go
well i shoot the special this week in
dallas yeah but that was my last show
before david you want to have a good
show yeah
so david will come in the back and go
two guns for like me and him killing it
would go two guns
so i walked back like a shooting
flamethrower
um the second show the thursday night
was tough for me
it's tough for everybody yeah they're
not all great man so you just noticed
because think about this late show
thursday night most people have to go to
work the next day yeah they're at work
that day it's late they're drinking
i didn't go on that show started late
not by my doing so yeah
10 30 you get on at like eleven there's
like what 12 people if you're a beast i
try to do this one bit that didn't work
what happened
alien bit where and that you know
there's a stool on stage yeah and i'm
like you know what i'm gonna do a karate
kick
it's so intense tv that's what i'll tell
you that's that bit was so intense yeah
i kicked the stool and then i i noticed
that that group that main table went
yeah he scared it he scared everybody
but because i was in the back of the
damn stevie doing
like if i saw alien gray on the street i
would want to get in a fight with this
alien gray and i thought of it and i'm
like oh i'll kick the stool it didn't
work at all it was intense
yeah but don't but here's the thing
though
when you do when you do one joke if you
do a joke one time at a show and it
doesn't work so just
no no no no i want you to listen right
now please
just give me a sec you need a spray ball
a water spray i know he's like one of
those dogs
you guys thought of a a new shirt sit do
another shirt that just says steve
listen yeah that that'd be it yeah
i'm here that's all in the shirt
the shirt will be me and you and it's me
covering your mouth yeah go ahead i'm
dude you didn't say it yet all right um
just because a joke doesn't work one
time in front of one crowd it doesn't
mean you dump it you you got to try it
like three four times
and then you can then you'll see and
then you like you manipulate there's
legs
and also like i told you stevie like
even like re
like moving the words around rearranging
the words your delivery
you you told me that last week when
we're sitting down here now let me ask
you this
jeremiah's got road dates right am i
ready to do that yes like a guest spot
to do that because tempe improv is in
two weeks hundred percent yeah and keep
in mind the last time i did combi
was at the 10 pm this would be this will
be your return this is my redemption
yeah
because last time i was like forty
dollar bitter forty dollars
you know i did a whole no i'm telling
you you know dave i think you should do
that again yeah absolutely not see
you're not listening to me
you're not listening to me
that was the most painful thing in my
whole entire life i quit for 70 years i
was thinking about overcoming that you
know like you going to return to the
cowboy right now it was packed thank you
cowboy
edit that out right now but stevie think
about this thing you think it was in the
green room andrew schultz me david lucas
i was nervous to meet that guy schulte
yeah yeah because i didn't know about
him but everyone like even david luke is
like damn still be kind of funny i'm
like yeah dude like he's on the show
yeah i'm doing he's funny oh david said
that yeah that's a lot coming from him
i was like dude your whole body was fun
that night we did kill tony yeah the kid
that roasted him yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i take him on the road sometimes oh you
use him too yeah yeah yeah that was cool
yeah yeah steve i also want to want you
to remember something else and this is
for everybody anybody trying to do
comedy like you know when you have when
there's a bad night there's like a
recipe that you have to remember that's
happening right now that this is a group
of people that don't know each other
from all walks of life all different
economics uh
stages in life different ages and
they're this organism that is coming
together that you have to make them
agree with you with through laughter
that ain't easy
you know what's the hardest job so
sometimes it's not going to work
sometimes you get a group of people who
are just ha you know it's a weird buzz
it's a weird box and then they're vibing
off the other table and then they're not
into it and maybe they weren't feeling
the opener or maybe a feature
no i'm listening to you i'm listening to
you but then also you like it's not good
if you go out especially when you first
started crushing every time like that's
not real no i felt that that second show
on thursday i felt it i'm like and you
should that's what you want you know
what though steve can i tell you
something i don't think that four years
ago
you would have been able to
like
go on stage
as much as you're doing it right now
have a bad set and then want to do it
again
know but this is because
he had that bad set thursday night but
then friday go hey come tomorrow oh i
was there two dude i was there two hours
you didn't no but i was there too
you were getting your shots up in the
gym i went to the habit i bought a
cheeseburger i did the whole thing well
he texted me he goes what time should i
go hey he goes okay i'll be the right at
eight no no no stevie you gotta get
there early no no i'm telling you and
then he showed up i was here like two
and a half hours earlier he showed up
early to the improv show too yeah
is the stool strong enough for me to
kick in
be like dude
can i say something that's not a real
audience i know but and they're like you
know it is an important process
like no there is an important thing
about going through open mics and going
through these dumb little shows you know
like this this actually isn't this
process is like you are you're being
spoiled right now a little bit you know
what i mean and it's okay time to stamp
that out no no no
it's definitely time stamped well that's
steve this is important he's getting the
treatment i got yeah you're getting like
yeah exactly what do you mean by that
but there's not a natural way it's not
then like you you there is something to
to be to to make your fellow comedians
laugh
is a process of gaining their respect
and that's how you get other shows i
mean that's just a process that a lot of
us went through you know like
especially in la like a lot of people
from out of town they're really spoiled
these are out of town comics let's say
they're in like iowa someplace and
they're they're at the improv and then
like the certain comment comes into town
the place is packed yeah and that
person's doing a guest set or they're
featuring or they're like uh middle and
they think that's what comedy is so
they're like oh wow i'm always
performing in front of all these
headlines i'm ready to head on and then
they come to l.a and they're like nah
man nobody knows who you are yeah you
know you you were in this like friendly
fun show that they were there to see
this person that's not the natural
progress that you need as a comic to
grow but also i skipped a step then hold
on but stephen
but stevie that's your path yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like you know right or
wrong it used to be a knock on me like
oh he didn't do open mics yeah my but i
did open mics i get it
but not like traditional comics like
eric or lucy k but you stopped you
stopped and then you came back and
you're doing sold out shows yeah but i'm
just hoping that's your path i didn't
plan on doing i just it's something that
makes sense now i'm telling you stevie
it doesn't [ __ ] matter that everyone
gets like everyone's trying to get to
the same destination yeah yeah you're
getting there a different way yeah yeah
yeah and there's not a knock on it
that's just there's a and also like
those open mics there's no pressure [ __ ]
those people
the there's gonna be pressure when
you're doing stand up live or whether in
phoenix like you at the heart dude you
have to go on before schultz david lucas
chappelle lacy myself like that's a
different sort of pressure yeah dude
the real pressure coming that's what i'm
sure the micros aren't getting that but
you're saying i have to get their
respect no no no no no no no no i'm
saying something i'm saying it's a
different process i'm saying it's just a
different process when you're doing
those type of shows like it's like it's
there's no to me there's no knock on
performing in front of comics there's
nothing wrong with that no because
they're able to do that you know the
poor process there is that you're you're
trying to like you still have to do a
show you're doing a show
i hate when it becomes this thing where
like because there's other comics there
now you think well i'm not gonna i'm
gonna perform for them and you you start
not doing your thing no you know the one
that's the cream rises to the top man
and you don't stay here
yeah you find your way so and you should
continue to challenge yourself by going
to those not warm rooms right that's
what i'm saying yeah okay
oh dude if dude that makes sense no
nick's right so the guys who like
obviously david lucas and chappelle are
did you go through that did he show all
of them david did but but he was doing
that kill tony that killed tony's a
rough round that's but also if like i've
had comics i've brought with him before
where i'm like oh are you getting up
around town are you getting spots like
no i just wait til i go on the road with
you i'm like i can't use you dude
they're they're saying this ain't the
that's not you need that that's well
you're not gonna get better yeah
yeah this is my argument to that it's
like those open mic rooms i don't
consider shows because you don't even
know how to gauge it like if it's
working or not but you're working on
yourself you can you're working on your
materials you can gauge it oh yeah you
can but like the lab like the labs dope
as [ __ ] the ha has that outdoor room you
can do some certain nights on laugh
factory and stuff yeah you're doing fine
you know what i was there for their open
mic at haha club because that's how
early i got there okay and it was a huge
difference between the show you put
out yeah because i went there because i
met the emcee to that and it was imagine
what you would have said you'll see it
was that that battleship
that was actually a better show
it was depressing yeah
she was special next week i mean one kid
was reading off his notepad okay let me
try this one out blah blah blah okay
though
that's just a part of it yeah all right
then i'll do all of it you should there
you go i'll do all of it let's take a
little break from chatting away with
stevie and big air griffin
hey man a lot of y'all are on diets and
you're just not getting the nutrients
that you need i'm not even worried about
that because today's program king of the
sting is brought to you by athletic
greens all right we're talking about the
health and wellness company that makes
the daily nutrition really really simple
man and listen we got enough struggles
going on you got busy schedules poor
sleep your exercise just life in general
work listen it's tough to get on the
right diet so once you check out ag one
by athletic greens all right we're
talking about a super food product that
brings comprehensive and convenient
daily nutrition to everybody all right
it's basically a multivitamin one scoop
we're taking care of all that one tasty
ass scoop of ag1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
prolacts green superfood blend that is
fantastic and it tastes amazing all
right and also you know what else
they're gonna do for you guys i'm gonna
hit you with this i'm gonna give you
some vitamin d yep athletic greens are
gonna give your immune system all right
free one year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com kats today again all
you gotta do is go to athleticgreens.com
cats to take control of your health and
give a g one a try
hey bros i'm trying to do a solid right
now i'm really trying to help you boys
out because a lot of y'all losing your
hair
and listen my show is a real wienerfest
and i see a lot of dudes losing their
hair and here's a little here's some
stats for you two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
bros in the us suffer from male pattern
baldness did you know that and my
friends at keep offers simple
stress-free way to keep your hair it's
cost treatments are just ten dollars per
month keeps offers generic versions
discreet little package shows up so
nobody has to know you're getting your
theo vaughn on all right keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors
prevention's key though man before it's
all gone you gotta start alright and
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act right now before
you look like george costanza if you're
ready to take action prevent hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash k-a-t-s
all right to get your first month of
treatment free that's keeps.com
k-a-t-s to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats
all right who's a
know you keep distracting me with this
this is these vampire eyes yeah those
guys so today we got some debate clubs
some king interstingets uh a couple of
crazy cat confessions that i really like
and uh we started off another uh
possible contestant for the cat's dating
game oh the last one got married
yeah but not to the guy with me brandon
theo eric and stevie my name is alabama
but i go by bama for short
go time
go time
you feel me wait rewind it i want to
hear it again my parents for that one
that's my dog in the background um i'm
24 years old i live in salem oregon with
my dog whiskey
i work in the mortgage industry so i'm
constantly working in my free time i
like to work out hang out with friends
go on spontaneous adventures anything
outdoors really i'm looking for someone
who is you know ready to date not just
to [ __ ] around is genuine fun she's a
man active has a good sense of humor you
know can handle my sarcasm and attitude
and give me [ __ ] back that's what i need
so if you guys can help um i'm seeing
someone already
i
that's colin christian right there
so fellas uh if you want to date alabama
god bless you bama's dm's about to be
like
yeah it's gonna be flooded
i guarantee she gets a video of a guy
who's a huge auburn fan burning the
shirt right girl i do this for you
what's going on there that's herself she
gave she gave us permission to look at
her social we won't give out her
instagram handle until after the episode
airs but or next week's episode airs but
uh oh they'll be lining up for her god
they're lining up for that damn
holy moly send in a video why you think
you're a good fit for alabama address it
to alabama
and 45 seconds or under
we're not trying to have like yeah you
don't see movies first of all
you're not giving out i'm gonna i'm
gonna search alabama and then she's
gonna come up you know what i mean
yeah
happy people go to who follows cats
in alabama oh don't fight just gave him
the trick well then boys
just randomly laughing look at them
like no that's not in real time
i've always heard the best time to take
a picture is after people post and
they're like oh let me see it and then
everybody's like they're laughing
uh yeah good let's get ten of these a
show
you wish you'd be ten stephens get like
five
there ain't ten baddies like that
submitting these videos yeah they don't
need to use it that's a bad one it's one
baddie and nine warlocks like i can't
find a man
oh so you're saying this is rare there's
a rarity yeah that's rare
you just made a lot of chicks feel bad
who just said
i actually think it's like we just have
less girls but the ones who do watch see
they're bad yeah yeah uh the problem is
we can't have a man who we try to hook
up because he doesn't get enough suitors
oh what's the algorithm like then so
there's not that many people
yeah yeah yeah but ten percent of half a
million still fifty thousand right
so there's fifty thousand women
uh but uh so theo has more girls
my crowd's all all dudes this guy's got
a king at her sting it for us and then
i'm going to cut it off he has an
amazing original king or sting song i
think he wants to like challenge little
brows but here's his king and her sting
at first
king of the stinger
using the bathroom might go just ready
for work
she's stinging that
ain't gang buzz buzz
my new song i said cats on the phone
i always say so yeah
what was this question again going to
the bathroom while you're sleeping and
others like getting ready i'd sting it
like you got to keep it sexy man yeah
sometimes like if i eat one of those
al's hot chicken sandwiches like that
that hot lava i don't know my girl
doesn't need to see that listen i have i
go to the other bathroom
oh yeah
what are you doing like every time you
get asked what the [ __ ] you think i'm
doing down there yeah i'm doing work i'm
not with that in that little bathroom
like that
no she's getting ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no one wants to
start
i thought that was an easy easy stint
now stevie's apartment has no choice
he's like hey i'll take the eggs over
here yeah yeah cause the kitchen and the
bathroom yeah that's all in the bedroom
[Applause]
all right just a second
stevie you got to set a picture of the
the ac i mean all right i'll send you
baby air freshener all over the eggs
you know what i need you know what i'm
going to upgrade we that's why we're
doing it
jeremiah's already sent out a petition
uh here's uh his song cats on the phone
and and the video is like do all the
rappers have to be white though i'm just
wondering
like drake if he was a hot dog eating
champagne you know
he's got the mic who's gross
who's that talking
it's him but i think it was pulled from
one of our
episodes but i gotta work in the mall so
friday night is going down i told my
wife leave me alone
i smoke a joint on my couch we're king
in this thing on my phone
[Music]
this thing
[Music]
that'll be a dream i look up to until
then i need some help on the youtube
timestamp y'all kill me with the rest
old school coming holiday reposting this
always be so gang gang you'll be coast
smoke stick with three seas buzz buzz
when i wrote this steve spread his seat
on the street for the people he griffin
got them credits and was on the beat you
the king of this thing enough king and
the crew true fans of love and respect
what you do we know what's going on
y'all didn't get backed up let's take a
moment of silence for a little black
button
y'all told me to get my wraps up
[ __ ]
[Music]
we might have a theme song off
dude you know why i like it because he's
a keto bubba smart it's really unique
and his voice yeah his voice is dope
yeah
[Music]
i don't know man you guys they have some
talented fans
bubba bart's over there man
a new king and a sting album steve gonna
do a track i'm gonna do an r b song
you guys i don't know
yeah i mean this guy i really liked his
uh his hands he was really good yeah i
got that production was unique i thought
his approach to the check out steve like
he's an american idol judge
hey carson daly hey carson daly take a c
[Applause]
oh yeah but we have to turn around let's
do that man we'll run out of place we
have buzzers or we just do it here yeah
a little bit my more diversity i want
some female vocalists do you know what i
mean ask it a lot
i mean
they got to be out there they're out
there
you know what call to action from
stephen
female vocals female vocalists
point out that ten percent
women assemble and there's four i'm like
yeah that would be amazing dude yeah but
five of them are like this what
oh 860. is that right uh i saw it there
too oh a60
this guy looks intense from sweden
scotland okay
hey brendan theo eric stevie eric
pumpkin seeds it's your boy sean coming
at glasgow scotland
i love the podcasts i listen to them all
multiple times can't get enough it just
makes me happy listening to your talk
[ __ ]
i'm here today to see you all think of
that all natural hair
that god's little secret
i'm talking about then pumpkin seeds
they don't call it nature's viagra for
nothing
i know my boy thiel's ears popped up
there
neck chin look up
two tablespoons of these little bad boys
and you end up with that all day long
thick piece
that little soldier that will never
disappoint just please guys give it a go
you'll never look back give it a go i
seen you theo in january of 2020 in
glasgow at the o2 i think it was called
and you're absolutely brilliant loved it
mate looking forward to seeing you
brandon we are there gang gang voice
does this guy have a pumpkin for him or
some [ __ ] yeah what's going on you uh i
don't know the man loves that really
evidently it's like a a natural effort
is it i i i enjoy a nice pumpkin speed
yeah pumpkin pie
especially when they roast them and mock
them i think he's saying it it's it's
good for your dick that's what it does
give you girth yeah i thought i thought
you said mine
fire them up look it up so you can show
oh gotcha gotcha yeah it's hard to
understand i like some some roasted uh
pumpkin seeds yeah so it gets your dick
hard that's what i'm guessing dick
harder makes it bigger it makes it
bigger i mean [ __ ] it make sure you [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
it makes it bigger what it makes it
bigger the corn of my boy over here and
you know you're gonna grind it up and
snort it hell yeah
oh wow what so
fluted
uh it said it in the
modulate some markers you guys got some
seeds are often used in traditional
medicine
uh in the
management dysfunction wow all natural
oh wow yeah theo suffers from this so
let's send theo some pumpkin speed i
know i'll get a bunch of old ass
pumpkins rotten right now from halloween
so good yeah that's that's i didn't know
that i didn't know that so king
that's why you know for women it's
makeup companies that stay in business
forever yeah because you know with
serums and eye creams and like paint for
men
look at how everybody's reacting you
just say anything about a dick and
making it work better yeah we're in
we're all the way in i don't have dick
issues yeah i'm gonna get some pumpkin
seeds theo has a hard time getting hard
certain substances he does i don't i
don't think we're telling tails sugar
coating steve just go right in
steve would be a terrible therapist yeah
so your dick you're having problems with
it you're talking about dick problems
he said it about a thousand times on
this program okay oh we're gonna say
he's trying to go that girl you had to
slide down the hallway to try to get it
up yeah i was trying to get blood into
it so i slid down the hallway
all right let's see what this gentleman
has
hey so king interesting
student loans i just finished uh dental
school okay
and i looked at my loan balance i'm
sitting at
six figures right
actually three hundred and ten thousand
yeah
dental school i went to what so that's
that's the king you're staying at what
do you guys think staying at this thing
it's almost
invested in what there's no
tangible asset really you're just
investing in your brain he's questioned
his whole life
it's that synaptic hitter investment you
know
that's the uh obligatory use of the word
hater for you so
you think guys
student loans check out the big brain on
brad
gang buzz
uh it's tough right because student
loans you're investing yourself and
let's say
what's the average salary of uh a
dentist i don't know maybe 150. man i
wish you guys had a computer
but uh so so let's say it's a hundred
grand so it's investment you're going to
pay that off you know in what probably
six years
i don't know man it's a it's a tough
thing you know but they were saying like
if you had kids and let's say your kid
want to be a doctor by the time your
kids ready to you know perform surgery
they said with science and everything
like doctors are almost going to be
eliminated it's going to be done by
robots and the technology is going to be
so advanced
so he's going to have all these loans
300 000 is that right that's for that's
that dude to be a doctor way more he's
definitely
so it's like you know i get if like
you're reinvesting into the school like
you know you're paying for the school to
be you know to be in business and you
know it's just it's a tough thing like
what is that 300 000 for
like you know what like like what are
you actually paying for you know so does
it need to be that amount of money yeah
well it's also like when you know i
played a major division one uh football
school and they would give you
scholarships and they're like well then
their argument is we're not going to pay
you because you're getting education
like i'm not getting education though i
majored in [ __ ] football right you
gave me the easiest classes i walked out
here with a degree i don't know [ __ ]
besides how to play football so then
being like oh we gave you a degree like
that that's the trade-off it's like you
[ __ ] know what you're doing you give
me these [ __ ] classes the kids got
the degree behind me couldn't even spell
chair
first day of school the first day of
class he goes hey man i spelled chair i
started laughing he threatened to beat
me up
he has a degree behind me was like this
[ __ ] he didn't know how to spell
change no man he's from louisiana oh god
well i mean i don't know it's like it's
like you know you you
you the he got the guy invested in his
future yeah and that is a lot of money
but he will be able to pay it off how
long will it take him well it depends on
like like you know five or six years it
depends they wanted to take a long time
because yeah interest you know they
wanted to take this
300 with interest you know it's gonna be
tough i don't think there should be
interest on it no it's [ __ ] up yeah
why is there interest on it like that's
like that's credit that's it's a scam
man it's like it feels like it feels
like it feels like a racket such a
hustle like i don't mind you like you
you know i don't mind you charging
because you have this school and you're
giving them this knowledge that can save
the world change the world change this
person's life but then you also want to
so i i'm i'm i'm stinging the
interest on the loan
and like semi king and like i get why
you're investing in yourself yeah i'm
staying in the system of yeah yeah yeah
yeah king and him invested in his
different knowledge
i i say king if you're going to college
with a plan i agree if you know what you
want to do perhaps these kids don't know
why they're there
i was just funneled into like college
didn't know what i wanted to do i went
to economics i have 70 grand of of
student loans and i had no plan i liked
econ but you don't know the value of the
[ __ ] back when you're that young you
know you're just buying
beer and
yeah it's a whole thing you went to
school here yeah yeah where'd you go
yeah i went to usc for a little while i
had a whole
do usc yeah yeah yeah i didn't i didn't
graduate from usc and it was just like i
had i just i didn't know what i wanted
to do either you know like actually my
mom and my stepfather they actually met
working at usc together so like i i got
to i didn't have to pay tuition so there
was pressure there too for sure it's
like you're my you got to go here
because you're not you know that's like
i don't want to go here you know i
didn't i didn't want to do that at the
time so i didn't know what i wanted to
do so that's what i'm saying too though
like what i don't like about the system
is like they're making you decide your
life when you're 18. before you even go
in so you have no idea you know you have
no idea so it's like you're going and
you're like oh all right and now you
feel this pressure of like because how
many people don't really want to do the
things how many people go to college and
they go you know what
i i took two years of this stuff it's
not really moving me anymore everyone
besides like the engineers i want to do
something and even those people are like
maybe i don't want to do this like if
you do that first then you transfer but
people that go to major universities and
major in like [ __ ] journalism or
communication so what are you gonna do
with that well
you're literally just trying to
figure out your life you know and like
college is like being independent having
fun like that's the experience
college professor for like 15 years you
want to argue with him it's a nightmare
yeah
so king it conditionally
yeah it's holiday season man it's
popping i'm sure your girl or your mans
is like oh i want this diamond ring i
want this these diamond errands i need a
diamond embrace or whatever it is man
build a brilliant piece with my friends
at blue nile that's right man don't
settle at blue now.com choose from more
than 200 000 all right diamonds
ethically source gia graded diamonds all
right what do you need rings earrings a
pendant they're all they're gonna love
it all man and uh you just gotta do it
quit going to the store and paying crazy
prices blue now got you covered man if
you need advice they have they got it 24
7. legendary service with 30 day returns
all right
um
if it's not perfect no problem a 100
satisfaction guarantee shop stress free
with guaranteed free shipping and
returns all right mark the moment that
matters with jewelry from blue nile all
right and king of sing listeners and
viewers get 50 bucks off 500 all right
this podcast exclusive offer includes
engagement rings oh hollow a lot of
y'all gonna get on one knee man use code
kats that's code cats plus every order
is insured ships free and arrives in
discrete little packets so it doesn't
give away what's inside shop stress free
and find your forever piece go to
bluenow.com today listen if you're a
gamer you're a podcaster podcast
listener maybe you're binge watching
your favorite show and you're like man i
don't have time to make dinner i don't
want to break from this stuff cool man
let grubhub take care of you man let
grubhub take care of you because grubhub
works hard to serve restaurants so they
can work hard to serve you and you like
panera let me hit you with a little deal
get a free delivery perk on your first
order from panera 15 or more order
through the grubhub app or online
grubhub we serve restaurants all right
so this is uh we'll move on to some cats
confessions we've got two today um what
kind of confessions you'll hear oh what
up king of this thing
uh this is for the confession hotline
uh my confession is
on my senior trip
high school senior trip we went to the
bahamas
and on the first night
i got really really drunk
and i ended up
like kind of i was dancing with this
girl
and i was i was blacked out this is what
my friends told me i was dancing with
this girl against a railing on this boat
on a boat party
and
i was like leaning back and forth
started to not look too good and the
girl was still in front of me and she
went for a kiss and i started to throw
up and i ended up throwing up in her
mouth
and then i turned over the railing and
she ran away
so
uh if she ever hears this i'm sorry
that's not really a confession
that's like like i thought this was
going to go like he pushed him over
or he killed the girl in the bahamas by
accident where is this going but that's
like that's just like it's embarrassing
yeah that was just like he just
embarrassed himself and it is what it is
feels better about he threw up in her
mouth in her mouth
oh she needs therapy
how about this no
like like he didn't look i'm sure he
didn't look like he was okay and what is
she doing going like this
like she going in maybe it's like a
mexico like
school trip that senior frogs well we
know he's white and rich oh yeah if
you're going to like the bahamas on your
senior bahamas yeah yeah and you're on a
boat yeah i'm like get out of here man
what does he look like he's probably a
handsome guy huh
anonymous confessions yeah uh everybody
hit the hotline if you have your own um
here's another one this how long until
this turns apology line we're like a
real cereal calls in like a straight up
killer say yo man i was a [ __ ] laurel
can the other day i [ __ ] cut some
dude's throat
king or statement
we're just all silent
what
yeah please don't
this one will take you for a ride
there's there's twists and turns i like
rides
hey guys i got a confession
um
i'm a wanna felon right now
i've been running for six years without
any retail theft so what i used to do is
i used to wear a suit and tie
take a alpha f3 hand key into target
i would go in there unlock uh you know
15 20 games
throw them in the car a bunch of other
stuff baby monitors that was two 300
bucks throw them in the cart
and then throw a bunch of good clothes
in there and then like a garbage can and
a mop
and then uh i would have a receipt from
earlier in the day or you know maybe
when i walk in i'll buy a soda and what
i'll do is i'll walk out i'll walk right
through the registers put the receipt in
my mouth as i'm putting my coat on or
you know whatever holding my receipt so
they see it i look the cash through the
eyes i tell them hey you have a great
day or to say something you know reverse
psychology type of thing well um anyways
i've been running for six years from a
year of jail time off of that and
i abandoned three
children
and started another family and have two
children with a different woman
in a different state as long as i never
go back to that state they'll never
extradite me
so i've been pulled over
and they
wisconsin won't take me
um they won't extradite me outside of
the state of wisconsin don't say where
you're at and uh
that's my impression
i i do want to go back and take care of
it and deal with it it's really sad
having some trouble right now i'm on
suboxone they're used to iv heroin
cocaine
and uh you know withdrawals is are not
fun plus jail is not fun
um
too old for that [ __ ] but anyways
um
yeah that's my confession
oh that's awesome
in all seriousness i think that uh i
think that this guy is doing he did this
as a i don't know like a cry for help
you're reaching out if you want to hear
what people really have to say i mean i
i just feel like hey dude you need to
take care of this i think you would live
in with a lot of guilt and the stress of
that you're not going to survive here
here's my question though the does the
guilt come from because where he can't
come back whatever state is his wife and
kid there and he can't come back and see
them yes yeah he abandoned him
but he's on the right you're right eric
like literally that's what he need i
this was like almost three minutes i cut
i cut some stuff off and you cut some
juicy [ __ ] out no no uh just he got more
specific of some of the incidences when
he was rolling out with the car and he
like talked to security and management
he's just like yeah we're all set on
that yeah
but uh he
he said he was like i don't know i'm
just kind of looking for encouragement
maybe to like do the right thing and go
back well i think that you look the
here's the thing that's a jail time
though he said one year oh did just do
that yeah he's got to do it
but it just didn't make him you know but
at this point now that it it it actually
might be more now because he's uh
but listen guys like look the point
about this is you're reaching out for
help you know you want to take care of
this you know your family probably needs
you you started another family i i think
you're like living in this moment of
feeling like why did i do this the
thrill of you doing it was the whole
thing i don't know why you know honey no
no no no no from the sound of this this
guy got a thrill out of like fooling
people you know a little bit he made a
point to make sure yeah yeah yeah
you know reverse psychology you know so
now at this point now you know you
fooled yourself out of like living a
proper life so just own up to what you
want to do do you have to just decide do
you want to own up to this take care of
it get back to your regular life get off
the drugs work on that stuff go back and
be a a father to your kids and and deal
with this right deal with it you know
you've conned yourself out of having a
real life now you could do the reverse
yeah now he also i wouldn't want to go
to [ __ ] jail or prison either for a
whole year and probably longer than that
now he's been invading the cops is it
not an option for your family whatever
state that's in to go to where you're at
yeah can they come or is that just that
relationship so [ __ ]
dis you know functional that they can't
come because if they can get to you and
you have an open relationship with them
then they they should come to where
you're at yeah taking away from a year
from the kids and i think to me longer
i'm kind of with them like dog if you
don't have to go to prison yeah but at
this at the same time though he's not
going to be able to get a regular job
now he's not going to be able to do
anything you know they they know well
hold up guys i have can i do my
confession i have a confession oh please
no brother
so every time i go grocery shopping
um i always get a red bull
the deal is two two for four
but every time i do self checkout
i do this
i take both cans i only scan one
so i'm only paying for one can of red
bull so you're paying two dollars
instead of four
i get one for free
and you just do it for the rush huh yeah
i look right at the guy too it's a game
to me i look right at the guy do you
think it's a gamer do you think you want
to save two dollars
that too right
[Music]
i'm stealing a red bull i'm stealing one
red bull
now you're doing this once every time
i've been doing this for about two years
now okay so about ten thousand dollars
already everywhere i hope this
manager
about ten thousand dollars in red bull
now we'll bail you out if you get caught
so is that wrong is that stealing
because the look at it it's not stealing
because red bull they make a lot of
money right
yeah what are you robbing him
yeah banks make a ton of money you want
to rob banks dudes these guys this guy's
playing brad pitt
it's okay that i'm taking it from him
don't they make a chin back me up bro
[Applause]
you always
but stevie if you took that same
approach with every
product in your life that's wrong isn't
it correct wrong was wrong all right so
i owe them in the men's huh just stop
doing it here's my thing stop doing
here's my thing red bull's gonna be fine
stop doing it yeah can you stop doing it
for me all right we'll edit that whole
absolutely not you're anonymous you're
anonymous and then um no we're gonna
stop doing that guys that's like on
those gangling videos or whatever it is
when it's like yeah we shot the guy that
it's like anybody who know like is
familiar with that guy knows it's him
like it's his whole body like tattoos
yeah yeah
go ahead nick uh in high school when
we'd go to movies and stuff
i'd go in the garbage and i'd get the
large popcorn and sodas and get the free
refill and i'd break it and then be like
oh i dropped my popcorn or my soda and
then i get free ones and also
and also in the trunk of my car from
like every fast food place yeah i had
like the large cup and i would i would
bring it in but you're you're strapped
for cash like struggling kid right oh
yeah it was a feral child yeah there you
go you gotta do what you gotta do but
also y'all some [ __ ] criminals and
also me and eric aren't engaging in this
conversation to do a confession now dude
we do we're vulnerable right now i'm
leaving
i was eight years old at a safeway that
we used to always go to and this guy was
making copies like some business
businessman was making copies and to get
the candy was a nickel remember those
nickel things yeah you put nickel and
grab the candy well he was there and he
was like busy doing some so i took a
nickel and my brother was with me and
then i went and got my candy he found me
because he obviously he was important
he's making [ __ ] copies dude he
picked me up big dude picked up my hand
and spanked the [ __ ] out of him
in the middle of the store
yeah he's lucky my papa didn't see him
doing that and then my dad my dad's like
why are you crying i'm like this guy
spanked me he's like why the [ __ ] would
a random guy spank you i'm like i don't
know my dad
hulk hogan walk around [ __ ] safeway
looking to beat this guy's ass that's
the confession that guy kept you from
being a criminal for life and you ratted
him out yeah i don't know why i'm a
snitch
i never stole again ever in my life well
when i okay so i was a kid we were at a
restaurant with my
kid party i don't like the kid part
recent
no sorry i haven't i was anyway hashtag
good guys stevie yeah um and so you know
we're getting a take out
you know we're we're we're taking food
home and we had a nice fancy restaurant
so like this stuff came in like this
sort of like silver tray it wasn't
silver but it was like a nice
thing
and so for the take i i took put the
whole thing in the back oh damn
you know
when we got home
my mom opens the the take home and she
sees that i took the actual [ __ ] yeah
that's not too bad i think the thing but
that's the that's the one of the ones i
can remember oh i'll switch on my
grandma face do you rest in peace please
rest on my sorry steven's current events
[Applause]
she's dead now so she can't get in
trouble but uh whenever we go to the
outback steakhouse she was older lady
yeah you know the real nice steak knives
oh yeah she every single time we would
go there she would steal the steak
knives people do that i went back to her
house and she had yeah 40 outback
steakhouse and she doesn't eat steak
we just just won the night my mom my mom
we would go to like hey that was better
you're getting better at these things
but we would go to like buffets yeah and
you're not supposed to uh you know you
don't they don't give you a take-home
box with buffets yeah there's no
take-home there's no take-home but my
mom would bring a big-ass purse
and with like
tupperware
tupperware
and bad good [ __ ] so mama she
that's really not even stealing she
would go like go get some go get what
you know and then she would like you
know put food into it
so she would go home with like we had
this big bag
see i like that
that was a real confession oh bro
growing up i did more [ __ ] eating
runs with my mom than i can imagine oh
you
died my mom didn't have a lot of money
and my favorite thing in the world to do
was go to chili's we would it was that
was like our five-star restaurant baby
chili's yeah
i want my baby i would get a four minute
british
i knew it was a big deal because my mom
would take us there she'd have a lot of
money she was like i got paid to date so
she'd take me and my brother to chili's
i'd get a full rack of ribs and wash it
down with a chocolate sundae and my mom
was like then my mom yeah i know that's
why i'm sad then my mom was like you
guys want anything else oh my god damn i
was bawling i was like y'all take
another shake my mom's yeah keep going
keep going and then the bill will come
my mom's like i'll tell you i'll meet
you guys outside and i was a kid i was
like no okay it was me mom outside and
she was like i'll just i'll pull the car
up and go then she had a great camry
samia brother just walk out so many and
she would speed off i'm like what the
[ __ ] when did you figure out she was uh
when did you figure out she was a a
criminal dude even just now
as i'm saying how loud i'm like yeah my
mom's a thief
dying in town
you were
yeah and that bill is not cheap full
rack of ribs yeah that's expensive yeah
chili's i don't know yeah a full 32
dollars that you guys got
so chili's our red bull watches we're
busted right
i think you're fine no you're busted me
and eric are good yeah this was a while
ago
seriously because no because the thing
is you have sports people that watch
this no you're good hey did you did you
know who you got to worry about they
already got paid for the cam
yeah
i didn't do it dude
come get you hey did you and bobby as
kids ever get caught stealing
you're like a batman
did
villain
so we go to the mall oh wow and uh come
on yeah my brother still the sample
cologne that's just sitting there no
we'd ask for those but then sometimes we
would uh yeah no not this i'm talking
about the one that like you know you
remember the green polo
before polo sport had a gold top the og
green green gold top or dracar nowhere
dracar yeah we get bottles of that yeah
[Laughter]
he smelled fantastic
like a million dollars he was gucci or
he had some gucci yes i'm fancy yeah i
did sure shout out to justin spends
every dime he has on shoes
yeah speaking of uh bobby this is
somewhat of a cats in the wild it's a
deep fake from brian monarch who
he does awesome [ __ ] yeah brian's
great oh [ __ ] bob don't like this video
i'm just like
bob don't like this do you love you
because i brought this up i was laughing
at him and he didn't say nothing
he don't like that video
is it because bobby's getting big yeah i
thought this was bobby
you just keep [ __ ] it's the ice cream
yeah you've seen this he said i'm done
all right let me get that that could be
him in like five years
this guy's nice with it man
this guy's so frustrated
he's like come on man this is how you
help people
yeah he does not like that video
that video is hilarious yeah brian
martin's obesity
but that could be bomb in a couple years
right if he doesn't do something you
know i'm wondering let's do it
with my brother man let's say something
bob like we gotta switch up your diet
what else yeah as long as he's happy
huh staying away from carbs more protein
vegetables
it's good for everybody keep going
stevia go ahead
we also got a cats in the wild from a
million people tag us in this yeah yeah
lots of these will get over and over but
this is uh brian uh he's got a little
side hustle as a street vendor
is that callan is that short king cowan
yeah short king cow brian count
so many people tag us in this but i
don't see it as much you know
he's a resemblance yeah i do i see it
you do yeah what's he making eggs
pastry music is fire
okay
a little bit i love people little bit
[ __ ] like that that guy's a little more
handsome than cal let's be honest yeah
fair enough because i got like an ethnic
yeah yeah some ethnicities and stuff
uh
we got some debate clubs to close us out
all right let's close it out
oh i ordered aaron rodgers jersey nick
nice the yellow one
yeah with the green numbers i thought
you'd like that i could couldn't love
either of those brett favre or i don't
care how much what he still brett favre
aaron rodgers i guess i love more now
more than ever i love aaron more than
ever he's a hero
yes doing the lord's word and state farm
came out and said like
they're not gonna do [ __ ] they don't
like that he misled people but they
support the right for people to make
their own choice
yeah yeah it's called america
that's one of the first advertisers kind
of like stick by him
stick by
someone who's going against like the
mainstream
yeah the woke left narrative well i have
a different feeling about it and we'll
get to it i knew you would yeah i knew
you would i you know in part of me but i
have to because you know i like to argue
yeah i'm dead are you but i know nick
loves aaron rodgers
and freedom
so that's why i brought them like oh
actually have something to say yeah yeah
you know what i'm trying to say the
assignment went let's do this yeah you
know what let's go
it's tough to win an argument against
eric but i love doing it same thing i do
with my dad
he lights me up with politics well we'll
uh play that one right now
what's up you king in the sting thoughts
i'm out here in denver colorado
making them 3d printed bad boys gang
gang parts
let's get to the real question though
who do you think had a worse week that
one bite bad boy dave portnoy or like
covet crook aaron rodgers
that mean no
yeah it's more like aaron dodgers
dodging uh no but here's what's he
dodging now here's what i have to say
about he's dodging this has nothing to
do with to me for me this has nothing to
do with whether he was vaccinated or not
that's not the issue no he never said he
was vaccinated
no no but you when i if you're immunized
if you ask him he know he knew what the
hell he was doing okay they did they
know he knew he he missed everyone knew
i don't know but the nfl knew no
no no that's what i'm saying he knew
what he was doing with with that
question that's not the point okay there
are a lot of people in the nfl who are
not vaccinated correct and they don't
miss time because they're doing what
they need to do to make sure they that
that this doesn't happen to them right
this guy wants his cake and eat it too
so meaning meaning aaron rodgers if
you're if you if you're the leader of
this team and you and you are
doing what all that went through in the
off season if you're going to say i
don't want to get vaccinated that's your
choice i respect that choice but that
now means you have to live your life by
the protocols that they have in place
you can't be at halloween parties okay
you can't be doing all the stuff that
you're doing you have to make sure as
the leader of this team that you're
doing everything you need to do to make
sure you're on that field
and if you're not doing that i got a
problem with that okay now all this
stuff about
him saying oh i'm that you know
when he knew what they were asking you
know they're asking you do you have the
vaccine pfizer modern or johnson johnson
that's what they were asking and he
misled because he didn't want to deal
with that i don't care about that that's
not why i have a problem with him what i
have a problem with him is he ain't
living up to his responsibilities they
lost the game they could have won if he
was there they would have blown them out
they could have won and they would be
eight and one with uh with now being
able to be in the lead for the buy in in
the thing so this ain't about freedom
this ain't about none of that it kind of
is though it kind of is though because i
think so because is it fair that you
have the most
the most in shape healthiest people on
the planet literally on the planet where
if they get covered we know from stats
that he has a 99.999 percent to survive
then check this out you're going to
investigate just say that
that's basically what he's saying no no
no that's what i say now if he can't
come out the gate no yes he can because
his team knows the team knew everybody
knows
no no no the team knew everybody knows
that's what i'm saying so if you feel
this way about freedoms own your [ __ ]
well that but they just come out and be
like then he can't play no yes he can no
i can't that the nfl won't allow him to
play no
if he you there are a lot of people who
are playing right now who are
who are out saying i'm not vaccinated uh
the the quarterback for the uh the grams
is not vaccinated um there's a couple of
them who are like i'm not i'm not
vaccinated they can play yeah they just
have to live they have to follow the
protocols so if you're not vaccinated
and you get coveted you're saying follow
the protocol if you're not if you're if
you're not vaccinated and you get
coveted in the nfl now you can't play
for 10 days if you are vaccinated and
you get covet you just have to have two
non-uh two negative tests and you can
play all i'm saying is this yes dude you
can play in the nfl if you're not
vaccinated because it's outdoor stadiums
and stuff man they're not indoors
you need to then follow the protocols to
make sure that you don't get coveted
that's fair that's all i'm saying so
what i'm talking about is this don't
tell me about freedoms and stuff cause
you know what you should be doing then
champion the [ __ ] he should be at the
podium going like i did not take it i
didn't want to i don't think i need to
and you know he won't get as much of a
backlash now you're saying that's what
i'm saying own your [ __ ] he's a he's a
he's an arrogant narcissist no come on
dude listen to be great
michael jordan is a narcissist for sure
to be great at anything
the people that are great they got huge
egos but they also have a lot of people
that like them so kobe rest in peace
michael jordan no i i i understand that
but what i'm telling you is that don't
take the fact away that he's a huge
egomaniac and what i'm saying is this
what he did
he
he should have just to me owned it up
front just own it that's fair that's all
i'm saying he should have just owned it
because now he's coming out with i'm
allergic to two of the things in the
vaccines like okay where was all that
[ __ ] before he could have said that
right at the podium i'm not going to
take the vaccine because i have i i
don't want to do this for whatever
reason it is and then you know he could
be like but i'm going to make sure don't
worry i'm making sure that i'm doing the
thing now he wanted to have his foot in
both worlds now as far as the question i
guess dave portnoy or aaron rodgers in
roger's gonna be fine and i would bet a
good amount of money that ian rogers
would come back and take his team to
super bowl yeah
good team and they're really good
they're good but that you want to piss
off aaron rodgers yeah yeah yeah enjoy
that he's going to light this league
apart yeah for dave portnoy i don't i
don't i'm not going to sting either when
we talk about whoever's had a debate
club who's ever had a worse uh week or
whatever aaron rodgers can be fine he's
gonna light the nfl up with dave portnoy
you know with him and these allegations
coming out with the way he's addressing
it i kind of [ __ ] with because you know
a year ago two years ago with this
cancel culture it was oh she said this
about him he's out and he said she said
but we care what she said not what he
said and it [ __ ] these people so many
people that we know it [ __ ] them dave
poor and i went hold the [ __ ] up here's
a receipt
of dms and texts when i when me and her
hooked up here's a receipt of her
contact me to hook up again
me and her joking around her reaching
back out to me her coming around again
so her saying she had you know
depression and suicidal and they called
the cops oh yeah call the cops
look through the records the cops go
there's no record of them calling the
cops that never happened
so for him to fight back to the what
he's doing and and getting his voice out
there i i think it's it's it's good for
the cause man let me justify the red
bull thing
now debate club should stevie go to
prison
no no no no no no no i want to go
seriously now i'm like worried but this
is what it's similar to okay i thought a
great deal about this you know how
you're at like um carl's jr or jack in
the box or in and out berg
it's like asking for the water cup right
hey can i get the water soda and filling
it up with 7-eleven now
now you're you're stealing technically
from the coca-cola company you're
stealing
up right because you lied saying you'd
get water but you're not getting water
you're getting seven up
what do you think about that chin first
of all
you know what i do in this situation i
always go like this hey man can i get a
water cup
i hit him with this
you know i'm guessing
this needs something up
when i go like this let me get a
watercolor this means
brown carbonated water
this is seven up or okay yeah yeah yeah
they're stealing right chin and they're
stealing seven up right chin they are
kinda yeah
yours is a little different it's
different though it's the same
difference man you know what you know i
know you're tuning in
but uh i
i know i thought you're gonna have a
different stance on uh on what rogers
yeah say yeah i got you again
i even got me because i agree i'm like
yeah that's fine if he came out with up
front that's fine no people i like the
way he's championing it now i don't know
what i'm saying people are making it
about this thing about this is a
different
it's a more nuanced discussion and
you're you're talking about different
subjects so if you're saying like
i thought you were different if you
don't like the fact that they're making
people they're not making people get
vaccinated they're they're saying hey
but but it's sort of like you're in a
rock and a hard place yeah i want to
work so that i can't work unless i do
this so if you have a problem with that
i understand that but what i'm talking
about with this is a different thing
this is about like he let his team down
all right he let his team down all right
and that's that's what they like
and they lost the game they would have
won which i think helps aaron rodgers
like yeah all right we'll see suspend me
see what's up now turn and turn how many
games you guys want to lose how many you
want to lose until i come back you're
not winning a game because that other
quarterback ain't [ __ ]
i know but just love it
i saw this on a sports show and i agree
with them i love watching uh marcellus
wiley and emmanuel archo are they
[ __ ] on rogers no but the thing is
just because you have power doesn't mean
you should exert it i disagree you know
i just agree uh i think he's in the
right no i don't i don't know you know
you know power isn't always like
you know hey
i'm not anyway i'm not gonna say
anything because i was gonna make a
point that we had to time stamp out
anyway but
yeah when you have power just because
you when you have power over something
you know and you uh
you know i mean you know it doesn't mean
you have to uh you know
but
but if but if regulating power is also
real but also if espn cnn the woke left
for coming out you trying to cancel you
and you have a platform you have power
different thing though but i'm just
saying that's the time to flex on it
yeah that's the difference because
because if this is jordan love who does
this they cut him yeah yeah now listen
the other guy in terms of this other guy
what you're talking about it's like
yeah the guy because he's like he's he's
in his 40s they've tried to cancel many
and he's like you know he these young
women are coming after you they go after
him they they they're hitting him up in
the dms yo yo so look the real issue
isn't about like what's happening with
them the real issue is about how we
society look at these types of
relationships so my thing is like then
raise the age of consent or what what
makes you out there comfortable like
what what age is it that you're gonna be
like this is okay because it shouldn't
be about how old this person is
obviously this is about how old the
other person is so like i said look to
me it's like then let's make it look
what's the minimum age to me if you can
rent a car you could [ __ ] a older dude
that's 21. okay 21. there it is you know
what i mean it's 26 i'm saying is it 26.
they're making 25. make it 25. but
because if a 21 year old is with a 40
year old and you have a problem with
that yeah then then don't make it legal
yeah my thing is too it's like with poor
noise stuff
it's like you know the the
this took real heat when her mom found
out about what she did and the way he
treated her and it's like well hey mama
your daughter takes no responsibility
she's the one that flew to nantucket
she's the one that sent those
promiscuous dms she's the one that had
sex with them then went back then sent
more dms so your daughter's gonna take
no responsibility with this none this
reminds me but this reminds me of that
situation with the we're not talking
about legal nature this is a legal this
is a girl who's of legal age i know but
this is not a young girl i know but this
is the problem with the same thing with
that situation with the baseball player
and the girl and they had this like he
was trevor bauer trevor bow i have the
same feeling i have about this who i
feel different about my message to these
young people is you know
you don't really
you the thing you're saying you want to
do you may not really want to do this
you don't really know this person and
this is what ends up happening it's like
you know
well no girl should be punched in the
face though no no no no no no no no she
didn't sign up for that no no no no no
that's that's not the that he went too
far my point is you're not listening to
me my point is
they didn't
you you're you're getting involved in
some situation with someone that's the
game you don't like a stranger yeah you
don't know the rules yeah like you know
like in that situation you're like she
thinks she wants to be punched in the
face or like she thinks she wants it
rough no she said go you don't want it
rough with a dude who's six four two ten
and a hundred four mile fast right you
know what i mean like you don't really
understand that he's playing a different
game
so then uh then uh the in this situation
with the um with this thing too it's
like yeah you know you're you're 19 and
you say you want to rape fantasy maybe i
don't think they think you do i think
there's people out there who've actually
been raped who'll be like no i don't
think you really want this yeah so i i
think it was like hey i want some
exciting sex and and here's a guy who's
rich and whatever the thing is you did
i'm okay with her being like whoa this
isn't really what i wanted to do i'm
also okay with portnoy getting on his
platform which is huge and his massive
amount of followers at barstool who i do
[ __ ] with and him be like yo that's not
how this went she said she slept on the
couch because you know she was so
traumatized hold up she slept on the
couch after she came back the sake time
after i had sex after she said she
misses this dick she came back we
realized we don't get along we argue and
she felt more comfortable sleeping on
the couch that's why she slept on the
couch she's like she's conflicting two
different things i know but the thing is
what i'm saying is like is there a point
here where like this guy like is the guy
like a little scummy yeah because he
like was he scummy because like he is in
a position of
power and authority and experience like
he's an experienced older guy
and here's this these young women who
like obviously they don't have no
experience in this kind of stuff and
they're getting involved and they're
going and then it didn't turn out
necessarily the way they wanted to or
thought it was and like let me finish my
point okay before you go
and so now they're they're they're
having these regrets and all this now my
point about that is this hey you have
regrets you made an adult choice and you
went and it didn't work out the way you
want the dude's not a criminal
because his life so let's talk about
that like i think we're not talking
about the right stuff
we should be talking about like yo
stop meeting strangers on the internet
and then when they don't go your way now
all of a sudden you want to be like the
person's a criminal let's cancel this
that's the problem right there we need
to be talking we need to be talking
about hey
you know don't don't go [ __ ] a
stranger
you just said it it's not gonna go the
way you want sometimes it's not gonna be
and then you know and also i think there
is a sort of responsibility of the older
person to be like yo i think you you
know and you know you know what's going
on you you know that you're you know
that you're like
swinging your dick around you're
swinging your money around you know
you're like hey i'll fly you out girl
just jerk off why don't you just check
them out
it's gonna be like wow
i'll have to fly him out just took off
was it a private jet was it like first
class like you know like you're getting
treated like you feel like oh this is
great this is great it's like that show
everyone's ever seen that documentary um
uh don't [ __ ] with cats girls we [ __ ] or
what is that what it's called girls
something about girls hot girls want it
that's the documentary hot girls want it
and it's about these florida it's about
this florida porn company who like
entices 18 year old girls to come
to florida to do porn and then you hear
their story and how it all plays out and
it's it's horrifying it's so sad when
you hear them you you hear what happened
to them you know like because they just
they're just manipulated and they're
just like you know so they don't know so
what i'm saying is this is a broader
question it's a bigger discussion than
just talking about is this guy uh you
know is this guy a predator is this guy
or is it the other side too being like
hey she's an adult she can she knows
what's you know it's like it's more
nuanced than that and i think it
deserves that type of discussion i don't
think anyone should i don't think anyone
should lose their livelihood right
situation so i understand why he's
coming out being like yo yo yo i got the
receipt
you know so it's like yeah
yeah yeah but it's like if my thing too
is like if we're going to get on
everybody who's been an [ __ ]
then like that that ain't just men
no all right that's the like if we're
going to talk about hey we should all be
nicer to each other again a larger
discussion that we could have but like
let's not make it all about like this
whole thing about us like it's just guys
treating people bad yep
what's this little diamond saying nick
uh this is the last one uh speaking of
older men who like young girls uh we'll
hear hers and also shout out she's
wearing the same sweatshirt i am right
now that's my podcast oh dope what is it
uh it's it's apn and greek letters
another podcast network so shout out
this woman you got some extra ones in
there i want to wear one i said the same
uh but let's see hi my name's angelica
i'm from los angeles and i got a debate
club for you guys
there's this video of jeff bezos
girlfriend mimi leo dicaprio and the
shoes are looking really excited i mean
i would be too
but my debate club for you is if you
were a young thot who'd you rather marry
jeff bezos or leo dicaprio
oh that's still
she's all up on him
yeah cause her man's a [ __ ] bad guy
from a marvel movie
he looks better look how handsome leo
but how can he compete
i think i was in once upon a time in
hollywood yeah that guy was in django
well first guy what a [ __ ] first of
all
first of all this chick is like 38 okay
so this ain't a young
thot a crooked she's a crooked dude yeah
yeah she's not you know so it's like
that's the hypothetical though oh okay
with the highlights
well it depends on what you're looking
for leo leo leo leo let's say because
steve wants to get [ __ ] by leo the
captain yeah so let's say one night yeah
that's different
yeah if it's one night you're going for
leo i mean you know either way you're
not going to be sleeping on [ __ ] ikea
furniture you know what i'm saying like
you're taking but if you're if you're if
you're talking about a life plan you're
going for bezos oh yeah
i'm going to space and [ __ ] every sunday
it'll be lit yeah but it's like you know
that just depends on what you're looking
for
and by the way by the way i have no
problem with somebody who is of legal
age just being like i want to experience
this yep like do you
take you take your take your chance like
if there's if you're like whatever like
we got to stop also making it seem like
like like like this girl do you if she
was like hey it's leonardo dicaprio even
if she turned to him and been like you
don't mind if i you know what i mean
it's like that's that that would be a
great pass
you know if you're gonna have a play he
he looks to you know what i'm saying
like you know how like they they say
like who who would your wife let you
know
a hall pass this is like a hall pass
situation you know like what's bezos
going to say like because here's the
thing about this situation i don't give
a [ __ ] how much money you have bezos no
yeah you ain't leonardo look at the
difference
so this guy this girl's like hey
i love your 100 billion but damn but
there's 200 million looking real [ __ ]
paper is dude you don't even matter
about the money no it's not even money
it ain't about the money with him it's
just look something when he didn't have
money he was getting [ __ ] oh yeah like
there's plenty of guys like that there's
dudes out here with no money does your
girl give you a hall pass no are you
kidding me what are you talking about do
you have a hall pass no from your
attention
no are you kidding me my god yeah uh i
didn't know she was 38 though uh that
december finger wave makes sense now
that leo's like no you're not 25 yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he likes younger but yeah yeah but bezos
is basically he's gotta be in the 60s or
something like that i think he might be
70 actually no he's in great shape for
70. but here's the thing though i think
he's at a point right now where he don't
need to date somebody she's 51. yeah
she's 51. yeah that's what i'm trying to
say
you know why because bazel says stupid
and her brother her brother released
that dick pic and tried blackmailing him
based like say what he's only seven
seven
yeah he's not 70. yeah he's balling i
mean
how old is leo he's probably oh he's
he's up there too uh 40 something that
he has to be 50. he's uh 40 44.
but here's a chart of how old leo was
and how old the people he was attached
to were
well he's a movie star
44 his current girl's 21. that gap just
keeps growing alpha male 1
no no no the problem is living the life
can i tell you something it's not the
hit it's not that leo's getting older
just they just keep staying the same
yeah these girls just that he's into
they're just always 22. yeah and every
year in college there's one graduating
to take another's place
look at the chart man look at the chart
there's one leo
oh yeah there's 30 22 year olds oh yeah
okay he's betting about yeah he's so
let's not act like you know killing the
game
good for him he's killing his tastes
just having him damn he was blake right
look at this guy what if it bothers tom
brady that's his girls with leo
should see the reverend he's all [ __ ]
that movie man i love this chart man
this is great yeah
definitely yeah but i think tom brady
tom brady is like it's like it's like
high school he's like the quarterback of
the football team yeah and he's with he
first of all he was with two baddies
his last chick got a baby with him she
was a super mom she's bad too yeah it's
tom brady that's what i'm saying i i
actually i don't know if you could if
the debate club is tom brady or leo
i don't know i think i'm gonna go with
tom brady tough one yeah i think i'm i'm
tom brady because he's he's a hard
worker he's a successful he's like you
know what i mean like so he represents
something so it's leo though yeah
when's what's leo's last good movie tom
keeps himself up once planet once upon a
time in hollywood
i liked him in january
he was good in january top three yeah
but did he make the movie or did uh he
should have won an oscar him and brad
pitt should have won both one oscars bro
i don't know man quentin i don't know
i'm just saying like tom brady just won
a super bowl at 42 44. and tom's always
in shape yeah leo yeah he got tb 12. he
don't need he don't need to be in shape
leo's leo
party off the reverend win man i mean
we're splitting hairs here they're both
studs yeah they're studs man there's
i don't think leo right now could go out
and play professional football oh well
he can back his ass off though he's a
great but i don't think tom brady could
be uh co-star with brad pitt exactly
once in hollywood
all right kids i'm in dallas this week
uh almost all damn shows are sold out
this thursday friday saturday addison
improv shooting my 30-minute special the
whole squad will be out there then
november
27th i'm at the everett theater thank
you in uh everett washington it's like
30 40 minutes outside seattle that bad
[ __ ] is almost sold out too and then
new year's i'm basically in fort
lauderdale bringing 2022 with your boy
and my fake friend oh that sounds fun
yeah it's uh the the new club out there
dania i think dania improv it's right by
fort lauderdale uh that's at the end of
the year get your tickets f f-a-t-k-z
dot-com but dallas this week baby i'm at
tampa this week at side splitters come
check me out at tampa and then next week
i'm at the miami improv and then the
comedy store by florida yeah i'm just
going to florida florida oh look i was
just in vancouver that i just went i'm
going to florida this week and then
going back to florida so come check me
out florida the the la joyous uh that'd
be nice yeah la jolla too stevie tempe
improv yeah we're going to be at flyover
comedy festival with scissor bros live
uh in missouri at the flyover comedy
festival and then yeah 10 p.m pro on the
19th
yeah baby love it all right guys love ya
we're out
king in the state
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way tonight he only finished boys in the
hallway this ain't the greatest show on
earth and what you call that eric
griffin with them he the nate dogger
podcast
get a whole crew sick it's the king and
the snake what up chin what up nick
stevie we weeby eric griffin just walked
in and got it lit you can't forget about
brendan he still need everything dick
dick they still got the bees and the
trap trapping
still the king in the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing ball and chain hair swang
like the rat king king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
in the state
king in the state
king in the state
[Applause]
king and the sting